so look at this
this is from the show and when Gavin
died
look at the tape
somehow in this show on this one night
he got taller
huh
well so what maybe well different shoes
why would a guy with a bad back suddenly
wear new shoes on stage
well you can't see his shoes there
though
oh
huh
[Music]
I I I I come and be shy
can I borrow that
come on L show me some heavy sold murder
shoes
[Music]
gotcha you son of a [__]
whoa
[Music]
seriously Jesus what now yo you guys are
sick with this [__] tribute you
killed him all you who the [__] do you
think you are me oh I don't know maybe
maybe I'm the highest bidder on eBay for
Gavin's real amp you know the one you
switched out to kill him or maybe I'm
the girl with the photographic proof
that you knew he was going to be
electrocuted you're all wearing docks
with thick rubber soles to insulate you
from that Electro [__] that you sent
through Gavin you know when you told the
fire inspector that you got lucky I knew
it was a lie I just didn't put it
together y'all made your own luck didn't
you you know I mean I have my degree but
even I know that's not legal proof Gavin
was the real deal you know and he was a
good guy and you killed him just for
what I said I'm still
a song about sucker punching
it's not just a song it's it
you know what ruby I knew that you were
a has been but it's worse than that all
right you're a hack and maybe I won't
get to see you in an orange jumpsuit but
you'll be in that orange build box apron
for the rest of your sad little hacky
life
security Gavin had Talent okay he was
metal he was real metal and you all
you're the opposite of metal all right
you're talc you hear me you [__] talk
she can't do [__]
we play the [__] out of that song
tonight and everything changes yes
let's rock hey do you mind swinging past
just over here uh thank you thanks I I
just I gotta grab my my bag and and I
promise to continue to throw myself out
so
I better not see you again
you're doing good work efficient
[Music]
okay just looking for some old-fashioned
cocaine hey narc
my name's Scott
and that's how doxology murdered their
drummer Gavin I I don't know his last
name for a song
yeah uh well that's uh that's a lot
ah
I got no proof
it's a whole lot of nothing just loose
connected dots I'm sorry I don't know
who I thought would take this seriously
yeah no you know what uh I think it's
good
you do yeah I think you make a
compelling case I mean some of this is a
stretch but you've shored up a lot of
the circumstantial evidence
I'm convinced
you think it's enough to say to your
boss
why would you want me to take it to the
VP of Finance at Nationwide
okay wait so you're not a cop
no I'm an actuary did you think I was a
cop
I thought you were an art everyone's
been calling me that I think I'm just
really bad at buying drugs
[Music]